TWO, THREE ENTRANCES?
WE’VE GOT TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS SOONER THAN LATER.
ANYWAY, EARLIER TODAY, ONE OF
THE STUDENTS INSIDE THE SCHOOL
WHEN THE SHOOTING STARTED.
HER NAME IS MEGAN HILL.
LISTEN TO HER DESCRIBE THIS
HARROWING SCENE.
>> I WAS SITTING IN CLASS, THE
BOTTOM FLOOR OF THE FRESHMAN
BUILDING.
WE ALL DOVE TO THE SIDE WHERE
THE WINDOWS WERE.
OUR TEACHER TOLD US TO GET TO
THE SIDE CLOSEST TO THE DOOR.
SO WE RAN BEHIND THE DESK.
GOOD THING THE DOOR WAS LOCKED.
I WAS SITTING RIGHT BEHIND THE
CABINET AND THE BULLET PASSED MY
EAR GOT A GIRL NEXT TO ME.
911 WASN’T WORKING ON MY PHONE.
APPARENTLY THE GUY GOT OUT
THERE, THERE WAS DEAD BODIES IN
THE HALLWAY.
PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN THE
HALLWAY.
MY SISTER WAS RUNNING.
SHE RAN FROM HIM AND GOT LUCKILY
INTO A ROOM THAT SHE FOUND OPEN.
>> ON THE PHONE RIGHT NOW IS
THAT STUDENT THAT YOU JUST HEARD
FROM, MEGAN HILL.
MEGAN, THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO JOIN US.
YOU’RE A JUNIOR, AS I UNDERSTAND
IT.
YOU’RE IN A ROOM.
THIS DOOR IS LOCKED.
THIS GUY IS SHOOTING.
TAKE IT FROM THERE.
WHAT HAPPENED FROM THERE, MEGAN?
>> AS THE SHOOTER WAS IN THE
HALLWAY, I’M NOT SURE IF I WAS
THE FIRST ROOM.
HE SHOT THROUGH THE GLASS
WINDOW, DID NOT OPEN OUR DOOR.
AND HE TURNED THE GUN TOWARD THE
SIDE OF THE WALL WHERE THE
STUDENT WAS SITTING.
HE SHOT FOUR PEOPLE.
ONE WAS DEAD.
THERE WERE THREE OTHER INJURED.
A GIRL WAS SHOT IN HER RIBS.
I WAS TOLD TO STAY CALM.
ALL I WANTED TO DO WAS HELP.
AFTER TEN MINUTES, I FINALLY
COULDN’T STAND IT ANYMORE.
I TOOK OFF MY JEAN JACKET.
I THREW IT OVER THE DESK AND
TRIED TO HELP SOMEONE IN FRONT
OF ME.
EVERYONE WAS TRYING TO STAY
CALM.
I FINALLY GOT A HOLD OF MY
SISTER MACKENZIE.
SHE WAS IN THE SECOND FLOOR
BATHROOM, GOT INTO A DOOR
SAFELY.
AND THE TEACHER -- THEY’RE NOT
ALLOWED TO OPEN THE DOORS FOR A
POLICY ON CODE RED.
BUT HE LUCKILY DID AND HE SAVED
HER.
SHE WAS PUT INTO A ROOM AND
SURVIVED.
IT’S JUST VERY TRAUMATIZING.
WE WERE TOLD TO LEAVE THE
BUILDING.
HEADS DOWN AND RUN.
THERE WERE BODIES ON THE FLOOR,
I’M NOT SURE DEAD OR NOT.
WE WERE JUST TOLD TO RUN.
AND HERE’S MY SISTER MACKENZIE.
>> HI, THIS IS MACKENZIE.
>> YEAH, GO AHEAD, MEGAN.
>> HI, THIS IS HER SISTER
MACKENZIE HILL.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO SAY I’M
SO SORRY FOR ALL OF THE VICTIMS
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
>> MEGAN, LET ME -- SO ALL OF
THE SUDDEN, THE DOOR OF YOUR
CLASSROOM IS LOCKED.
AND THE SHOOTER SHOOTS THROUGH
THE DOOR.
THEN STICKS HIS GUN INTO THE
CLASSROOM.
FOUR PEOPLE GET SHOT RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU.
ONE PERSON YOU BELIEVE IS --
DIED, IS INSTANTLY KILLED.
YOU’RE TRYING TO HELP A FRIEND
OF YOURS AND PASS OVER YOUR JEAN
JACKET.
AND WHAT HAPPENED FROM THAT
POINT?
I DIDN’T FULLY UNDERSTAND.
>> FROM THAT POINT ON, IN ABOUT
A COUPLE OF MINUTES, THE SWAT
TEAM AND POLICE BANGED ON OUR
DOOR.
WE DUCKED DOWN.
THEY CAME IN AND ASKED WHO WAS
HURT.
WE TOLD THEM THE FOUR PEOPLE
THAT WERE HURT.
THEY GOT THEM OUT OF THE DOOR
AND THEY ESCORTED US.
>> YEAH.
AND THEN ABOUT TEN MINUTES GO
BY.
IN THE INTERIM TEN-MINUTE
PERIOD, DID HE STAY SHOOTING
LONG?
HOW LONG WAS HE ACTUALLY
SHOOTING INTO THE CLASSROOM?
>> HE WAS SHOOTING INTO THE
CLASSROOM NO LONGER THAN A
COUPLE OF SECONDS.
HE WAS SHOOTING IN THE HALLWAY
UP AT THE CEILING AND DUST WAS
FALLING ONTO US.
AND THEN HE TURNED HIS GUN TO
THE RIGHT AND SHOT A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE.
>> AND THEN I GUESS YOU HEARD A
LOUD BANG AND THAT WAS THE
POLICE COMING TO RESCUE ALL OF
YOU?
>> YES.
>> I CAN’T EVEN IMAGINE WHAT IT
HAD TO BE LIKE FOR YOU.
AND YOU HAD YOUR TWIN SISTER WHO
WAS ON THE FLOOR ABOVE YOU IN
THE BATHROOM?
>> WELL, ACTUALLY, SHE WAS
ACTUALLY -- SHE’S IN THAT CLASS
WITH ME.
IT’S AP PSYCHOLOGY.
FIVE MINUTES BEFORE THE SHOOTING
ACTUALLY HAPPENED, SHE ASKED THE
TEACHER TO GO TO THE RESTROOM.
THE RESTROOM ON THE FIRST FLOOR
WAS WALKED, SO SHE WENT UP TO
THE SECOND FLOOR.
SHE WAS WITH A FRIEND.
AND SHE LEFT THE BATHROOM.
AND SHE SAW THE SHOOTER BUT GOT
INTO A CLASSROOM JUST IN TIME
FOR THEM TO LET HER INTO THE
ROOM.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOUR SISTER WAS
THERE.
SHE WAS IN THE SECOND-FLOOR
BATHROOM.
I DON’T KNOW IF SHE CAN HEAR ME.
BUT YOU HAD AN EXPERIENCE THAT
YOU WENT UP TO THE BATHROOM.
YOU BOTH I GUESS ARE IN AP
PSYCH.
AND THERE IS A FRESHMAN GIRL
THAT HAD SEVERE ASTHMA.
AND TAKE IT FROM THERE.
AND ALL THE TEACHERS HAD LOCKED
THE DOOR AND YOU GUYS ARE
RUNNING LITERALLY DOOR TO DOOR
AND THIS POOR GIRL IS OBVIOUSLY
STRUGGLING, RIGHT?
>> CORRECT.
WHILE I WAS IN THE BATHROOM, I
HEARD 10 TO 15 GUNSHOTS.
I RAN TO THE NEAREST CLASSROOM.
I WENT TO THE DOOR AND THE
TEACHER IN THE CLASSROOM UNDER
SCHOOL POLICY, THEY WOULD NOT
LET ME IN BECAUSE OF THIS SCHOOL
POLICY.
AND LUCKILY THEY LET ME INSIDE
THE CLASSROOM.
I FEEL THAT IF THE TEACHER KNOWS
IN HIS GUT THAT HE CAN LET YOU
IN THE CLASSROOM IN THE SCENARIO
I WAS IN, THEN HE SHOULD DO IT
BECAUSE IF THAT TEACHER DID NOT
LET ME IN, I COULD HAVE BEEN
KILLED TODAY.
AND I’M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
TEACHER.
AND AS I GOT IN THE CLASSROOM,
THE TEACHER LOCKED THE DOOR
AFTER ME.
EVERYONE WAS CRYING, TOO.
IMMEDIATELY, I CONTACTED MY
SISTER WHO WAS IN THE CLASSROOM
ON THE THIRD FLOOR, NOT KNOWING
ANYTHING.
SHE DID NOT RESPOND AND I COULD
NOT BEAR THE FACT OF LOSING MY
BEST FRIEND.
AND I HEARD NOTHING ELSE.
I DID NOT KNOW IF SHE WAS
INSIDE.
>> YEAH.
I WANT TO SAY THIS TO BOTH YOU
AND YOUR SISTER, MEGAN.
BOTH OF YOU SHOWED AMAZING
TODAY, MEGAN TRYING TO HELP THE
GIRL NEXT TO HER AND YOU
OBVIOUSLY HELPING THIS POOR GIRL
THAT HAD THIS ASTHMA ATTACK AS
SHE’S GOING ON THERE.
>> YES, HER INHALER WAS ON THE
FIRST FLOOR.
I WAS TRYING TO CALM HER DOWN.
>> WHEN DID YOU ACTUALLY
REUNITE?
BECAUSE HOW LONG AFTER WAS IT
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO FIND YOUR
SISTER AGAIN?
>> WELL, AFTER I GOT OUT OF THE
BUILDING, SHE TOLD ME THAT SHE
GOT OUT AN HOUR BEFORE ME SHE
WAS BECAUSE SHE WAS ALREADY DOWN
THE STREET WAITING FOR ME?
AND I DIDN’T KNOW SHE WAS INSIDE
BECAUSE I WAS IN MY CLASSROOM
AND TOLD TO SILENCE MY CELL
PHONE.
I FINALLY SEE HER.
AND AS I WALK OUT THE BUILDING,
I’M SEEING BLOOD AND PEOPLE
WOUNDED EVERYWHERE.
AND IT JUST BROKE MY HEART.
I COULDN’T BEAR THE FACT THAT
SOMEONE COULD COME TO THIS
SCHOOL AND SHOOT UP STONEMAN
DOUGLAS.
IT WAS LIKE A DREAM TO ME.
I COULDN’T BELIEVE IT.
I’M STILL IN SHOCK RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH.
I CAN’T IMAGINE HOW HARD THIS IS
FOR BOTH OF YOU.
BOTH OF YOU SHOWED AMAZING
COURAGE TODAY UNDER THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
NO CHILD SHOULD HAVE TO SEE THAT
EVER.
MEGAN, MACKENZIE, THANK YOU
BOTH.
WE MISS YOU AND YOUR FAMILIES
AND YOUR FRIENDS OBVIOUSLY,
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE A VERY
TOUGH WEEK AHEAD, AS THESE
FAMILIES AND SCHOOL IS